hello everyone before I get started with
this I'm just gonna say it amazing game
I have a small announcement to make as
you can see in the top left corner of
your screen as of today all of my videos
will be available on roku TV so if any
of you use roku TV I would ask you a
small favor of checking it out you can
find it just by writing a got motto in
the in the search bar in Roku and try
out the app is the buffering okay you
know is the interface okay so far it's a
pretty basic stuff you know you can just
watch the videos but which time there
will be some improvements and additions
so that being said I hope those of you
who are using Roku will will be able to
give me some feedback let's get back to
this game and it seems like Skynet
scenario from terminator is closer than
we think
this game here it was played between
google the google deepmind running the
alpha 0 algorithm against stockfish and
ok this isn't the latest version of
stockfish i think this is a last year's
the version of stockfish but it doesn't
really matter I think like last year's
stockfish was rated around 23 30 and
maybe this year stockfish is rated
around 2,400 so it's another big of a
difference what's interesting is that
deepmind only had like 4 hours of
training and what does alpha 0 mean
alpha 0 means that deep mine was only
given the rules of chess it wasn't given
any databases or any previous games
played or anything that could help it it
just had to teach itself by playing
against itself so after 4 hours of
running this office 0 algorithm deepmind
is now facing stockfish and you know if
any of you ever played against stockfish
you know how powerful stockfish is and
here is it's pretty amazing I've seen a
couple of games I chose this one because
I don't know it's just beautiful it's
like watching me cut out play only me
kowtow
that's 10 times as strong as me Kyle
it's pretty amazing I mean deep mind
makes stockfish look like
like a little kid trying to trying to
move the pieces around but you'll see
what I mean after I show you the game so
deep mine has the white pieces and d4
was played stockfish replies with Knight
to f6
we have c4 and c6 Knight to f3 and now
b6 we have the Queen's Indian defense g3
Bishop to b7 Bishop to g2 Bishop to e7
we have castles and castles b5 now it
captures on d5 and night to h4 by
google's deepmind c6 c capture son d5
Knight captures on d5 and now Knight to
f5 threatening to capture the dark
square bishop here and also this is one
hell of a square for a knight Knight the
c7 now it's very hard for stock fissure
to develop this Knight can get into the
game the pawns are blocking it you can't
develop the rook before you develop the
knight you can't play a move like c5 to
develop the knight on c6 because the
knight on d5 is hanging so stockfish
plays Knight to c7 and we have E for
Bishop to f6 and now Knight to d6 going
for that Bishop and b7 stockfish replies
with Bishop to a6 and okay this does
come with temple on the rook on f1 but
after rook to e1 now this Bishop is also
blocking the knife from entering the
game via night to a6 so stock fish is so
blocked in this is I mean this is stock
fish night to e8 trying to you know free
up some pieces and and get at least some
development b5 now Knight captures and
e6e captures on f6 and King captures on
f6 and we have Knight to c3
so deepmind is now down to pawns but it
doesn't matter look at starfish pieces
they simply can't be developed nice to
be 7 now this night is still in the way
you can't really do anything with the
Queen because the knight would be
hanging and while the knight isn't easy
doctors still can't push d5 so night the
b7 first and now comes Knight to e4 with
a tempo on the Queen Queen to g6 and now
h4 we have h6 by stockfish making room
for the Queen on h7 h5 Queen to h7 and
now Queen to g4 and already this comes
with a terrible threat of Knight to f6
check winning the Queen as the g7 pawn
is pinned came to h8 stopping this
threat and the Bishop to g5 this is a
this is one hell of a move such an
active square for the bishop but
stockfish doesn't capture it stock
fishplates
f5 if you were to capture the bishop
okay hg after sun g5 night Caterson g5
would attempt on the Queen Queen to g8
and after something like Queen to h4 and
Bishop to d3 getting the bishop back to
the defense h6 rook to e8 and something
like H captures and g7 would check King
captures and after Queen to g4 with you
know some threatening discoveries Bishop
to g6 and it's a pretty equal position
but this is only what my analyzing
software came up with it's it's hard to
imagine what google's deepmind was
thinking about after he offered this
night
so after Bishop to g5 f5 by stockfish
now Queen to f4
this pawn is pinned if you capture the
night you lose the rook on f8 night to
c5 and the Bishop to e7 this night
finally got into the game but now Bishop
e7 attacks the knight and the rook we
have Knight captures a story nights to
d3 and this comes with a tempo on the
Queen and also with an attack on the
rook on e1 Queen to d6 now with a double
attack on the rookin f8 also getting the
Queen out of the way stockfish captures
the rook Knight captures anyone we have
rook captures on e1 and now F captures
on e4 and stockfish is now up so much
material but it doesn't matter
deep deep mind plays Bishop captures Ani
for now attacking the Queen and you
don't really you don't really have any
good options here I mean if you play
something like Queen g8 Bishop captures
rook
so stockfish tries rook to f8 now at
least if Bishop captures rook Queen
captures Bishop but Bishop to h4 now we
have Bishop to c4 and this Bishop to c4
is pretty much the only move stockfish
can play there is no other move
stockfish can play this position is so
so dominating for for deep mind that
it's it's hard to believe once again
that stockfish is playing this with the
black pieces so Bishop to c4 trying to
get the bishop into the game and now g4
pinning the rook I mean attacking the
rook as it's been from the bishop if you
move the rock you lose the Queen
but Rock the d5 starfish now attacks
deepmind's Queen and we have Bishop
capture Sun d5 Bishop captures on d5 and
now rook to e8 check you don't really
have any options here you do have to
block it you don't want to block it with
the Queen so Bishop the g8 blocking and
now comes Bishop to g3 c5 now black is
trying to either play Knight to c6 or or
something it's very hard to develop
since the rook will be captured either
way now comes clean to d5 attacking this
Bishop twice the bishop is pinned of
course from the rook and also attacking
the rook on a8 and there is nothing
stockfish can do about this this is a
this is one ugly position for stockfish
d6 now Queen captures
rockin a8 and Knight to d7 okay now the
night isn't in the game but now Queenie
for again what's the idea here and the
idea is of course now deepmind wants to
trade Queens I see he is up the exchange
Knight to f6 now attacking the Queen and
the rook but deepmind simply plays Queen
captures on h7
we have King captures on h7 and this is
moved 35 the game lasts for like let me
just check the game lasts 4
a hundred and seventeen moves but the
first 35 are the ones that will matter
to you guys because now this is a
winning end game for white black is
black is up upon but why does up the
exchange he has a rock for a night and
this is completely winning even for to
humans playing but of course I mean a
computer like deep mind and artificial
intelligence like the mind doesn't have
a problem winning this endgame I will
just show it you know just for just for
fun
Ruki 7 was played in IG for now rock
captures on a 7 the Rope will now gobble
up all the pawns Knight f6 Bishop
captures and d6 Bishop e6 Bishop e5 97
Bishop c3 g6 Bishop d2 G captures on h5
a3 and it's you know I'll just show you
the moves it's a pretty standard and
endgame and I mean who knows
who knows what deep mines rating is it
would be pointless to analyze this it
could be rated for a 4000 for as far as
I know h3 Rock h8 simply it's it's a
matter of time but it's interesting that
you know how often have you played the
game and you had you've been up the
exchange in the endgame and it probably
took you like max 20 or 30 moves to win
the game but stockfish manages to drag
it out for for over 80 moves so you know
when you're playing the best moves this
is what it takes to win the endgame even
when you're up the exchange so whenever
you win win and then game when you're up
the exchange and like I don't know 20
moves it's it's because your opponent
didn't play very well but you know it's
it's pretty scary and I've seen I've
seen some other games I don't think
stockfish want even one game I think all
the games were won by deepmind and all
the games were
beautiful I'm not really that impressed
by the surprised by the result but by
the by the way deep mind is playing and
yeah okay this is like this is like
taking forever but I mean I will put the
PG end so if you're interested you can
really study the same game this could be
the greatest end game ever played in the
history of chess we have no idea how
strong deep mind is and you know
probably deep mind is currently the the
the strongest chess player the strongest
chess entity in the world
so after up to D 3 in this position
stockfish resigned to the game and I
mean it's pretty amazing I will put a
link in the description below where you
can check out it's a link to the PDF
regarding google's deepmind and you can
read a bit more about it
about it playing chess about it playing
go deep mind is actually dig man was
also using alpha 0 algorithm and it it's
the first program let's say that
defeated the world champion in a game of
go so naturally of next step was
attested in chess and you know there
wouldn't be any point in testing it
against humans since humans are pretty
useless against engines for growth for
like two decades now but testing it
against the strongest chess engine in
the world that's something else and
google's deepmind demolished stockfish
i'm pretty sure you can simply just
google it you'll find all the other
games I didn't really find a link to all
the other games I've seen people post
them online so yeah this is one game and
yeah like I said the part of the game
that interests you is till moved 35
where the exchange of Queen happens and
it's I mean it's a stunning game so yeah
that's the game I do hope you enjoyed it
and what do you think about google
deepmind artificial intelligence and the
alpha 0 algorithm in general yeah that's
it as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here
thank all for watching and I will see
you soon